acrid smoke hangs heavy in the air
across surf side
a constant reminder of the tragedy still
unfolding here
fires burn deep in the wreckage still
smoldering despite the storm
judy spiegel was in the building her
husband kevin who was away on business
knows this unthinkable purgatory won't
be over anytime
soon i do cry on and off you know
and you know try to comfort the kids and
the grandkids
is really my focus did your grandkids
know or
well yeah we told scarlett
that grandma's lost and we can't find
her
and you know she knows something's up
she doesn't know why
but grandma was always there to take
care of her and that she's not there
she's very concerned every day here
brings fresh heartbreak for the families
of the 159 people still missing
this time it was news of a report which
found major structural damage in the
vicinity of the building
and crumbling of columns in the parking
garage beneath
that was three years ago when the
building came down in the early hours of
thursday morning
repairs still hadn't started the
champlain towers north is almost
identical to the champlain towers south
which collapsed
it was built at the same time with the
same design
yet residents here still haven't been
evacuated
they want reassurances from florida's
governor that they're not in danger to
would you feel safe going to sleep
tonight if you're in the sister building
of this just 100 yards away
i know they are considering potentially
evacuating them
uh but that's something that uh you know
ultimately the mayor is going to have to
make the call on
you put all your all your fights in
there yeah yeah yeah
and that's it i'm
a few dollars here william has moved out
of his own accord with all his
belongings in one plastic bag
i'm very very worried i am 75 years old
in my
living every day every day with the
strength of the building could
we collapse the apartment block was
built on reclaimed wetlands like many in
this area
a study had found it was sinking into
the ground at a rate of two millimeters
a year
in the 1990s what we we found was
that the the land was subsiding was
lowering down
in several places when we see only one
building that is moving we cannot say
exactly why
so so with the champlain towers south it
was very localized it was just that
building that was subsiding at that
point
that's right
it could be months perhaps even years
before families discover
what exactly caused the building to
collapse devastating lives and changing
this beach town forever
now authorities are under pressure to
ensure it can never happen again
martha kellner sky news florida